bueno fundamentalmente lo que trump está
haciendo es una deslegitimación del
sistema democrático de los eeuu y
democracia en general en el mundo las
elecciones como él dijo en su momento
solo será legítima si él gana lo que
está haciendo es al mismo tiempo está
agitando movilizando en la calle a parte
de sus seguidores
que a su vez están encarnados como lo
vimos a llegar en esta manifestación que
no fue de millones como dijo su portavoz
sino que fue de miles por muchos de
estos grupos grupos paramilitares
milicias grupos de ultraderecha que
todos son fundamentalmente el rasgo
central que tienen expresivamente ser
antidemocráticos
o sea que aunque la comisión electoral
como ustedes acaban de mencionar ha
indicado que han sido las elecciones en
la historia de eeuu
hechos con más precisión con más certeza
y más fiabilidad aún así el presidente
la sigue desafiando y está jugando a ver
qué puede pasar en los últimos dos días
semanas y meses hasta que tenga que
asumir el candidato electo joe biden
señora aguirre precisamente qué podría
pasar en caso de que se resuelvan los
recursos que ha presentado el mandatario
se confirme la red
la derrota de trump pero él siga
negándose a dejar la casa blanca en que
podría desembocar este esta situación
bueno eso es la gran pregunta en donde
hay muchísimas especulaciones sobre qué
puede pasar
es casi una es como una apuesta es como
jugar a las adivinanzas digamos que
inicialmente
yo creo que trampa intentar dejarle una
herencia muy compleja la parte más
compleja de lo que ya es en términos del
corona bailes y otros temas
probablemente crearle una o dos crisis
internacionales especularon que podría
haber algún tipo de ataque quirúrgico
contra irán
y probablemente nunca acepte que ha
perdido pero al mismo tiempo se marche
hecho es una posibilidad se habla de que
incluso discretamente las fuerzas
armadas podrían indicarle que tiene que
irse aunque hasta el momento las
indicaciones son más bien grafos
formadas se adaptan y siguen el proceso
constitucional no imagino por el momento
que los militares le dijeran que se
marchará creo que más bien va a ser el
conjunto de lo que está pasando en la
sociedad americana y que algunos de sus
seguidores le digan que ya se acabó pues
señora aguirre muchas gracias por su
análisis y esperemos que se produzca una
transición democrática y pacífica